hi I'm Erik Bosse and this is a
breakdown in the walking dead season 8
episode 4 some guy
and yes the bullets were flying this
episode sometimes in ways that didn't
totally make sense or seem believable
but if you could get past that I
actually thought this was a really solid
episode that finally broke down as he
keels falseness and said goodbye to a
beloved CGI tiger that I'm sure MC was
very happy to not have to pay for
anymore I'm gonna break down all the
deeper connections that you might have
missed some interesting choices made in
the cinematography and possible cultural
influences but before we get to that
stuff let that start with the big
question brought to us by at Mi dancer 7
what was with those barrels and has
ezekiel change how so okay well that's
two big questions but i actually think
they're connected
so the barrels were referring to are
those toxic waste barrels that were
leaking into the ditch where shiva died
so let's dive into the secret of this
Sue's so it was kind of hard to tell
while you're watching this sequence but
this toxic waste was causing chemical
burns and skin abrasions on the walkers
that were following is zekiel Carol and
Jerry their skin became bleached and
severely pockmarked so on a literal
level this is just some good gruesome
grotesque horror for Ezekiel kind of
like those gross melted walkers from
season 5 but I think it also has some
metaphorical significance as all
discussed later this episode is all
about melting away Ezekiel's false outer
layer as the violence and the horror of
this failed mission shock him into his
true vulnerable self now these gooey
Walker's are these same Kingdom soldiers
Ezekiel led into battle and their
despicable miss toxic waste reflects the
morphine of Ezekiel's outer appearance
as he ends this episode looking as if
he's seen a ghost or you know a few
dozen of them now obviously Shiva's
death in the scene was a huge deal and a
lot of you were asking why she had to
die both narrative Lee and I assume a
general existential why but I'll get to
that and more thoughts in Ezekiel when I
discussed the deeper meaning later first
I want to talk about how this episode
compared with the version of these
events in Robert Kirkman's source
material so let's initiate our segment
well in the comics okay yeah it's great
so Ezekiel's defeat in Shiva's death go
down in issue number 118 The Walking
Dead comics and while the defeat is
certainly a tragic iOpener for Ezekiel I
was amazed at how emotional and
earth-shattering this
feel a big part of that of course comes
from actor Carey Peyton's performance
his heartbroken wail at the top of the
episode and his silent walk of shame
back into the kingdom just made for such
a dramatic and dramatic gut-punch
also in the comics this whole defeat is
told to a second hand by Ezekiel as he
narrates his shock in his shame but I
like this adaptation to place the events
mostly in the present as we see
Ezekiel's facade collapse in real-time
you can almost pinpoint the second his
heart rips in half now some of you may
have caught another possible wink at the
comics but it is a huge spoiler that
happens way later so if you haven't read
the comics and you don't want to know
skip to this time ok the Savior named
Gunther the Jeffrey Dahmer e-type guy
threatens Ezekiel by telling him your
head on a pike will will do just fine
okay while Gunther obviously doesn't
deliver on that threat this could be a
subtle foreshadowing of Ezekiel's future
death much later in the comic timeline
probably the most shocking twist in the
comics at least after negan kills Glenn
comes during the war with the whisperers
when several key characters get killed
in a surprise attack that leaves them
with their heads on pikes including
tragically our king now if the show ever
goes in this direction we're still long
ways off but the back of my mind is
really really dreading and seeing this
on screen okay let's move on to these
subtle interesting ways this episode
connected to past episodes in our
section callbacks okay this episode was
directed by Dan Lew a longtime editor of
the show and I believe this is actually
his first major time directing but you
can see how this guy totally understands
this show's visual language because he
made some awesome visual choices first
was this awesome jump cut from Ezekiel's
pre battle speech of the kingdom an
overhead shot of the kingdom errs
fawning over him to those same kingdom
errs dead that same affection for
Ezekiel causing their doom as they
shielded him from gunfire now obviously
this contrast has symptomatic with
significance that we'll get to later but
I also love how this is a visual
callback to the iconic closing shot of
the very first episode of the series
remember that overhead shot of Rick in
the tank covered by Walker's the
parallel this shot to the shot of
Ezekiel in the kingdom for shadows how
Ezekiel's own people will shortly turn
into monsters trying to devour him okay
I don't know if you guys caught this but
part of the reason this contrasts
jump-cut works so well is the music Lu
directed Ezekiel's speech to be so
hopeful and forward-looking and he
reused these same victory music that
played in the mid-season finale last
year that was titled rise up this music
of course abruptly cuts off when we cut
to the bloody aftermath of his battle
also Carol Lakes surrenders to the
Savior's posing as a weaker enemy that
then she really is just to lower their
guard before suddenly attacking them
remembered this is the same move Carol
pulled on the saviors in season 6 when
she pretended to surrender but really
had a trick up her sleeve it was a gun
she had it she had a gun on fresh leaf
yeah I actually really liked how this
episode compared Carol in Ezekiel as
role players this is a parallel the show
was brought up before and both of these
characters have hidden behind false
personae of charmers Ezekiel was a
zookeeper and a part time community
theater actor who now plays a part of a
larger-than-life
King to inspire his community and make
them feel safe Carol is a tortured
killer who has previously masqueraded as
a meek Suzy homemaker type so her
enemies will see her as less of a threat
which yeah they totally shouldn't see
her as less of a threat
in this episode Carol refers to the
decision she made to become someone
different saying how she decided but
life decided some things too I think
this is calling back Carol's gradual
transition over the series a change that
was both caused by her own actions like
burning Tyrese's girlfriend in the
prison and killing Lizzie in season 4
but really something life also decided
for her going back even further to
losing Sophia in season 2 and her
husband Edie using her all right let's
move on to some possible cultural
influences and references on this
episode and our segments under the
influence now I really like the opening
sequence of this episode with Ezekiel
getting ready for this battle this is
all shot like Ezekiel is a stage actor
putting on pieces of his wardrobe in
front of a green room mirror which is
exactly what this is for Ezekiel it's a
show this also reminded me a lot of the
opening sequence of the Game of Thrones
season 6 finale which opened with very
similar shots of each character
meticulously getting into their costumes
gradually leading up to the sudden
violence that that would happen that day
this scene even features some soft piano
music that evokes Game of Thrones light
of the 7 from that episode and in both
cases the music
Orr's these characters as if they're
preparing for a funeral that day the
shots of the kingdom soldiers saying
goodbye to their families combined with
the bloody aftermath was certainly hard
to watch both poor Ezekiel and for the
audience but I couldn't help seeing a
connection between these shots of
carnage and Saving Private Ryan and that
film Steven Spielberg took a commonly
romanticized historical event the d-day
invasion during World War two and
instead showed us the horrific violence
of the real sacrifice of those soldiers
severed limbs spilled entrails this is
what a 50 caliber machine gun really
does to the human body the saviors were
using these same kind of mounted machine
gun that the Germans fired on the Allies
landing on the beaches at Normandy that
day and as we pointed out some of the
gunfire in this episode was a little
unrealistic with Rick and Darrell's car
chase being a good example yeah it's a
little weird that machine guns could
tear apart human bodies but well let's
just kind of bounce off of Rick's Jeep
but in my eyes this Chase isn't really
part of the episode totally it's kind of
in a different world it's pulling
actually from another famous Spielberg
movie Raiders of the Lost Ark now unlike
Saving Private Ryan Raiders was actually
aiming to be a romanticized view of a
world war two ERA adventure so the
mission isn't like a debate between
holding a line and protecting human
lives it's more of a pursuit of an ever
important game-changing weapon which
passes back and forth between sides kind
of like a football in this case the Ark
of the Covenant is the browning machine
gun when they load it up actually in the
case notice how it's shot in a close-up
similar to the way that the Ark is
loaded up at the end of Raiders and yes
this action does go down in a very
heightened romanticized Raiders style
with Rick heroically leaping onto a
moving vehicle and fighting the driver
Indiana Jones does this exact same thing
so while this episode is all spielberg
which is exciting it's kind of mixing
eras of spielberg which is creating a
bit of this tonal confusion now speaking
of spielberg this may just be me but
this shot of Shiva's blood clouding the
ditchwater reminded me a lot of that
shot in Spielberg's the lost world
Jurassic Park when dieter gets
surrounded and eaten by the copies and
his blood seeps down the stream there's
also a shot of Ezekiel's bloody hand
bursting out of the corpses of soldiers
now this could be an homage to Brian De
Palma's iconic jump-scare and Carrie
with a bloody hand bursting out of the
grave now okay moving on from the
influences let's
look more closely at some of Dan lose
visual choices in this episode in our
segment zoom and enhance now I noticed
this in past episodes but I like how we
get a good look at his e kiyul selecting
the red feather for his hair on a
practical level this links him with his
soldiers the kingdom distinguishes
itself with red armbands red being the
color of its insignia that we saw last
season
now I actually wouldn't be surprised if
the color-coded armbands was Ezekiel's
idea this is kind of a theatrical
practical way that it's very much in his
wheelhouse but on a metaphorical level
the color red also marks all these
characters for death red is commonly
used that way in literature and cinema
actually Spielberg famously used it with
a little girl in Schindler's List but on
a character level this red feather is
also kind of a symbol of Ezekiel's
naivete it's the same accessory worn by
Peter Pan in his cap you know so in a
lot of ways the zekiel begins this
episode as a Peter Pan type a childish
warrior named Neverland utopia who
believes that he's invincible it'll
never die which I guess Carol then would
be the Wendy whom he's trying to
convince to stay with him and Neverland
I haven't really thought this metaphor
through but I guess in this version all
the Lost Boys die when Ezekiel crawls
away from their corpses he notices a
tiny flower on one of their armbands
that was given to this one woman by her
son earlier and it's interesting how now
this flower is recontextualized as a
flower for her grave and earlier in the
episode we get these close-ups of
Ezekiel preparing his dreadlocks as eCos
hair is a reflection of the power he's
trying to exude it's almost like a
lion's mane but later noticed how the
zombified version of Daniel grabs
Ezekiel's hair to pull him in the Kings
costume has become a literal
vulnerability just like how plain
pretend has made reality an even tougher
pill for him to swallow and let's look
closely at the framing of the shots that
open and close the episode early on
Ezekiel is framed in close-up filling
the frame unable to be contained as his
people clear the way for him the final
shot shows him in a distant wide shot a
long take of him limping back into the
kingdom as his people stare at him in
disbelief in judgment Ezekiel's changing
size in the frame tells the story of
this episode he begins as a
larger-than-life powerful figure totally
in control but he ends is a tiny
good animal limping home with his tail
between his legs and that brings me to
the deeper meaning of this episode it's
titled some guy a phrase that Ezekiel
says verbatim as he confesses to Jerry
I'm not your king I'm just some guy
earlier Ezekiel's called out as a con
man in a costume revealing that this
emperor has no clothes is the whole
point of this episode he's a part-time
theater actor who when discussing war
quotes Shakespeare and while his warped
worldview is useful in inspiring and
reassuring his people when the [ __ ] hits
the fan he doesn't at all understand the
reality of his violent world and the
death of Shiva is essential for
Ezekiel's awakening Shiva embodied
Ezekiel's hyperbolic unrealistic stature
even if you didn't buy a zekiel
heightened brogue and booming voice the
tiger was the big stick in the tangible
source of Ezekiel's power without Shiva
Ezekiel's character act doesn't really
hold up so now he must confront who he
is as a man and how ultimately he's just
some guy okay let's check in on the kill
count of this episode episode might have
seen the highest number of on-screen
casualties in episode yet it's easy to
forget that when the world of this show
is filled with walking corpses but I
don't think we've seen so many people
start off the episode alive and then end
it dead like bodies really hit the floor
this time topping the list as the
deadliest would be Carol by my count she
killed seven humans two of whom she
killed by opening those gates and
releasing walkers on them and at least
14 Walker's bring her total 21 but let's
be honest here
the real winner of this episode was this
inanimate 50 caliber machine gun this is
son-of-a-bitch wiped out nearly all of
the kingdom's army nearing by my count
34 people now I guess we could credit
the team of saviors operating it for
those kills but I don't know guys I
think in this case I'm okay with saying
guns kill people and now let's quickly
look ahead and make some predictions for
next week's episode episode 5 titled the
big scary you now promo footage makes it
seem like this will be a negan Gabriel
focused episode with the two bottled up
at the sanctuary after the season
premiere there's also some shots of
these savior captain's Simon Dwight and
Eugene and the other snapping at each
other in search of them all now this
does end up being a bottle episode I'm
excited to see where this could go
like the Simon Dwight storyline could
end up being sort of a reservoir dogs'
type story with the guy
is testing each other's loyalty in the
aftermath of a shitstorm meanwhile based
off footage and shots from the trailer
I'm wondering if negan scenes with
Gabriel couldn't up playing out kind of
like a Catholic confession in which case
this could be the episode we finally
learn negan's origin I won't say exactly
what his backstory is in the comics but
I have a suspicion slash theory that the
letter U in the big scary u title could
refer to the U shape formed by the lines
of a basketball court uh-huh comic
readers know I'm going with this do you
think Ezekiel deserves the trust of the
kingdom is there enough of a leader
under that kingly persona to carry the
remainder of the kingdom through this I
want to hear your thoughts in the
comments down below or you can tweet
directly at me at EA boss or follow new
rock stars on twitter at new rockstars
for updates on our videos now this video
is brought to you by our good friends at
loot crate loot crate is a monthly
subscription box service for epic geek
and gamer items and pop culture gear for
less than $20 a month you will get six
to eight items that include licensed
gear apparel collectibles unique
one-of-a-kind items and more it's great
there's always something that I would
never like thing to buy for myself loot
crate has supportive youtubers since the
company shipped its first crate so by
supporting loot crate to support our
channel sign up at loot crate comm slash
rockstars and enter the code rockstars
to save 10% on any new subscription or
click the link in the description below
so I'm gonna unpack last month's crate
it had the theme of mythical to get an
idea of what to expect the November loot
crate theme is unite and it contains
cool items from Star Wars Batman
guardians of the galaxy overwatch and
more you have until the 19th at 9 p.m.
Pacific to subscribe and receive that
month's great and when the cutoff
happens that's it it's over so start
collecting this great gear like this
video and subscribe to new rock stars
for deep obsessive analysis of The
Walking Dead and all this stuff that you
love and if you want to help us shift
this channel away from YouTube add
restrictions you can help contribute any
small amount to us on patreon big thanks
to all of our donors especially Laurie
Denning alright thanks for watching bye